[Music]
hey celebrities they're just like us
Hannah love is in the air let's talk
about it Jennifer Lopez according to Us
Weekly doesn't want to get engaged too
quickly to her boyfriend Alex Rodriguez
because she doesn't want to quote jinx
the romance they've been dating for like
a year and a half she's been married
three times so she knows what she's
talking about when it comes to jinx in a
marriage
what do you think is that real or she
just doesn't want to marry a rock yeah I
think that's real three marriages
already yeah yeah for sure something a
little different you know Sammy bullying
her that she just doesn't want to rush
it I think I believe her and I think
that's a smart decision and in
solidarity with JLo and a rod as to not
jinx their relationship I will not be
proposing to my girlfriend we have been
together for a month then we didn't
speak for a year and then we have been
together for three years since then and
it's on baby we got a dog we're in love
we like to do hellofresh
[Laughter]
yep things are great I got a spare room
lots of stuffs going right for a guy I
wouldn't you tell it I would cut out
that a month didn't speak I have some
questions about that it sounds like
something horrible happen enough to be
in a relationship and even though I
thought that that's what I had wanted at
that time in my life
and then I broke up with her and I
matured and realized that I'm a idiot
and then I reconciled and she was like
by the grace of God of like willing to
speak to me still and now things are
great but I think that's important
because there's lots of relationships
like that and not everything is like a
fairy tale three months three months off
we took three months it was like
together for a little bit I didn't make
enough issues didn't we take three
months and I just was awful person for
that three months and then I came back I
would ready to not be awful I don't like
yeah gotta get braces hearing these
stories I'm like why are these women
taking these men back but what happened
in your case I didn't least a couple
months cuz I got some but sort out
you know I mean that's better than him
not taking it three months and then five
years maybe hit a whole nother family
and a whole other state how y'all doing
the time that you need to do it right
yeah you're the jail oh I don't know
where I am I'm definitely not the jail
oh they're combining their finances
already so what's yes what isn't that
the whole point of getting married when
I read that - that they are combining
their finances I was like why they both
have the most money it's like you're
what are you budgeting for saving up for
I got a family plan now in 80 cheaper
each month I didn't want to go onto the
all-inclusive a Dominican Republic it
makes sense for somebody like me to get
married because I would like need her
like benefits and things like you know
you're married you know you're getting
into I think people have their reasons
to get married now is for jail or a rod
or like suffering in the elephant yeah
I'm sure that she's never had a cold she
looks so good there's no way she's
drinking virgins blood
she's 49 this is that she's 43
that's why Donald Trump look some people
who maybe did rush into it Justin Bieber
yes model girlfriend Haley Baldwin there
24 and 21 respectively they've been
engaged a month and people are like all
is it too soon and now it looks like
maybe so because they were photographed
quote distressed on some Paris city
bikes which is New York City's rideshare
service for bicycles
it actually it made me really sad
because it's for sure the city bikes I
have they don't work the gears break I
bet his bike broke and he was like this
and then they started crying I didn't I
didn't call a $20 taxi those pieces of
did you leave the city bank no
links to your account I'm not I do I
love Citibank I think it's a great
service I loved it seeing them in the
city I think it makes the city friendly
yeah I don't like them because I have a
regular bike and I think I should be
faster than them but some city bikers
I'm like trying to prove so what what
you don't like it because when a city
biker passes you on that tank of a
backup with only three gears going
faster than you and you're more
expensive with the carbon fiber I'm like
am i weak or something it makes me feel
bad I think it's weird that they don't
like somehow there's no helmet involved
yeah that's bad maybe that was maybe
they're arguing about helmet safety and
then there's just like we guys going
back to them neither them are wearing
helmets I was worried about that too but
they both have like beautiful long
blonde hair it looks like they're slowly
becoming the same person yeah and that
person
[Laughter]
like androgynous Li beautiful and in
there's also a video of it where you can
see many other people passing them on
the sidewalk and I'm like how are you
not stopping to gawk at them because
even if you don't recognize them who
they are they're just like clearly more
beautiful they look like a Norwegian Cup
yes they're just glowing
tourists like you need sunglasses to
look at them yeah I think that's what's
great about New York oh yeah like I have
somewhere to be I don't care yeah hey
Beiber got away Bieber's been dressing
so terribly recently that I think maybe
they just didn't realize just come from
my bouncin days I've literally seen this
exact couple cry the exact same way at
every bar music this is not a story it's
just white couples being out what do you
mean you're crying at a bar you're
making this guy in that with a drink is
liquor and you're ruining out nothing
cute Italy I'm not gonna call the cops
cuz they're not gonna arrest me
[Laughter]
someone's just capturing the regular as
date sad about I know that they're
celebrities and also any couple fighting
in public people are gonna pull the
camera out to like be like what's going
on here but it makes it's like a such a
bummer to me that like they can't just
have like a regular breakdown on the
side of the road they could just afford
a private car to get where they're going
like a private city bike yeah
[Laughter]
they should have rented the popemobile
house you saying it yeah and I do have a
shout out for us I do have a shout out
what's that shout out shout out comes
from notorious noe and the shadows
I clicked because I think Natasha is hot
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna do something different right
now I'm Natasha and I just love the
internet for all the strange and random
videos it gives us today I'm gonna share
some of my favorites with you that
feeling when you missed the email about
free cake in the conference room I feel
you buddy if I miss free cake I'm gonna
slap somebody
[Music]
this makes me feel so much better about
not wearing a bra to the convenience
store I mean this man didn't even put on
his pants or genitals you know for all
those times you need a prime number and
look inside a bear butt hole and find
nothing there but turds what do you
believe is the author's message
regarding immigration and immigration
laws I hate it did anyone read the book
this month just be honest with me this
is extra embarrassing because the author
is here yes those are my doggies and I
just love them and I love the Internet
hello I'm Jordan and once a week I'd
take a little more psychedelics than
usual and write in my journal these are
my thoughts feeling lonely here's what I
do open up the fridge and say how's
everyone doing in here
oh look at those little guys they always
manage to cheer me up this also works
for cabinets drawers and most bins
please note it doesn't work if the bins
are empty
this has been Truman Nations thanks for
watching today's episode as we mentioned
earlier it's Natasha's birthday there
today so we got our little please bring
that cake in the frame will you
heywhat single song
[Applause]
[Music]
you